[Music]
tick tock star siaka car dead at 16 her
manager Arjun sarin posted the news of
her passing to Instagram writing quote
no more words you will always be the
best artist rest in peace Sayaka car
according to India today the 16 year old
died of suicide at her home in New Delhi
India on June 25th police reportedly
told the local news outlet that she had
been battling depression in the four
days prior to her death and added quote
she lived with her family
her family is in shock and has requested
privacy no suicide note has been
recovered her manager also spoke with
India today saying quote I had a word
with her last night for a new project
and she sounded normal this must be due
to something personal workwise
she was doing well or is it an ear cut
they nude up with the uricani the zoeva
telecom but they are see I had a massive
following on ticked off with nearly 2
million followers
she was primarily known for her dance
videos
[Music]
she posted her last video just two days
ago furniture Hideki Kamiya not Geneva
looky her first video was this one
posted in 2017 et has reached out for
further confirmation
you